bonjour monsieur bénézet merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france à
vous êtes président de la branche des
cafés bars et brasseries du groupe en
national des indépendants
quelles sont vos impressions vous
appréhensions concernant l'application
ne se passa ni terre au sens des cafés
et des restaurants jour nous n'avons pas
le choix s'impose à nous parce que nous
avons été reçus par l'exécutif bien
avant le 14 juillet c'était la solution
confirmer nos établissements nous avons
consulté le parti n'est pas sanitaire
parce que sinon on allait vers une
fermeture nommé établissements vous
imaginez un été en france s'établissant
restaurant sant boi de disco texte en
séance un lieu festif c'était possible
donc nous avons accepté le parti de pas
salutaire parce que nous avons le choix
est aujourd'hui le pas ce critère est
bien accueillie par le client certains
joueurs qui sont on a commencé à le
tester dans l'établissement mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez puis nous avons pas
le choix
voilà c'est ce qu'ont fait ces
manifestations qui sont des
manifestations et en france ce sont des
manifestations fortes pour tous vous y
trouvez des gilet jaune vous ai trouvé
des politiques vous y trouver de
l'intérêt de lentilles dax vous voulez
trouver des petites passes sanitaires
surtout quand je veux dire aujourd'hui
déjà paris est dans une situation qui
est compliqué aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas de touristes et en plus nous avons
des manifestations dans paris qui bloque
la capitale dont je vous assure nous la
restauration nous sommes dans un état
désespéré et financièrement en
finalement ça veut dire que vous
préférez le passé ni trop en ce moment
tout à fait ce n'est pas une
personnalité on était fermés ou confinés
je pense que pour les français c'est
quand même plus agréable d'aller au
restaurant mais avec un peu solitaire
aujourd'hui il ya eu 90 aujourd'hui si
votre site ou s'ils n'étaient pas là
parce alité vous êtes exclu vous avez
l'exclusion de vous même c'est à dire
que vous pouvez pas au cinéma donc
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il faut se
faire vacciner en masse aujourd'hui la
vaccination de certaines de gauche
demande de l'objectivation obligatoires
chacun est libre de faire ce type si
vous restez chez lui presque chez lui et
au sens justement de de l'avant ce que
vous représentez est-ce que vous parlez
tous d'une même voix parce qu'on a vu
des restaurateurs à des commerçants
certains
steve o passé certains favorables à ce
passe d'indiquer où il était hors de
question on se contente d'être une
autorité de police à dire de la
directrice d'un petit yann opinion on ne
voulait pas de responsabilité pour notre
produit restaurateurs ce qu'on a obtenu
appelé rhône était parti de gardes
communaux roanne ans d'emprisonnement
aujourd'hui on est à 1500 euros avec un
avertissement préalable
on a beaucoup aimé c'est beaucoup a été
améliorée il attendait le conseil
constitutionnel a pas donné son avis
déjà il y aura une période d'adaptation
pour pour léguer le décret va quand même
être parce que c'est quand même le
contraire il prêt salariés il ne fait
que ça qui se met devant l'établissement
où ce qu'un ces panneaux est d'avoir un
portable à la main et de valider des
passes sanitaire de nos clients non
c'est une contrainte effectivement c'est
ce que vous allez à une baisse énorme
sur paris on n'a pas de tourisme et sur
paris et les grandes villes on a une
baisse énorme leur clientèle beaucoup
beaucoup de clients ne viennent pas au
restaurant parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
paschal eater de la nuque intel sur
tarki très âgés et qui n'a pas de pass à
lithaire bien souvent sneeze et donc
c'est ce que j'allais vous demandez ça
veut dire qu'il y aura des salariés ou
sans les restaurants qui vont être
embauchées spécialement pour vérifier ce
fameux qr code
vous avez des terrasses à fait important
il avait demande plus qu'ailleurs il ne
soit pas imposé sur la terrasse et la
même sens c'est le cas ils réclamaient
sur la terrasse dont il faut une
personne qui ne fait que ça imaginez
vous avez expliqué personnes qui
s'installe à table vous avez cinq
personnalités ans le sixième de la pape
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils s'en moquaient
ce qui se passe ça peut finir ça peut
dégénérer dégénéré en bagarre j'ai
toujours peur que ça dérape un petit peu
center banon vous ne vous servez pas
appelé la police mais j'avais j'ai
tellement de
quand on est près des gares les
établissements moi je dirais ça peut mal
tourner alors en bout ça on sait que ça
va coûter de l'avancé
manque que le confinement a mis certains
restaurants à terme ils ont été
contraints de mettre la clé sous la
porte est ce que le gouvernement vous a
parlé
peut-être un d'une certaine forme de
rémunération des dons en tout cas
financière pour embaucher quelqu'un de
supplémentaire pour vérifier ce choeur
code alors avec le gouvernement de
revoir vers le 20 août enfin près la
situation
mais par contre le problème c'est que
beaucoup d'établissements sur paris
étant donné qu'il ya personne chère mme
aujourd'hui paris est une ville
sinistrée
vous avez personnes dans les restaurants
c'est très très calme j'appelle moi tout
adhérent mais je m'appelle owen ils sont
10 me dis qu'est ce que fait marc fait
ben hamadi ont fermé ils vont fermer au
mois d'août mois m quand j'ai payé 1 rpt
un congé sans solde ou équipements
chômage partiel à leurs heures avec en
plus la charge
donc c'est très compliqué sur les
grandes villes sur lignon c'est la
montagne que ce soit les met sur la côte
moi j'ai beau regarder le temps qu'il a
fait en bretagne ces jours derniers
c'est pas fini donc des gens ne sont pas
sur les terrasses
marcel bénézet merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions vabres était en
direct sur rt fond je rappelle que vous
êtes président de la bombe des cafés
bars et brasseries du groupement
national des indépendants merci